Speaker 1: We continue to follow some of the most
important races that could determine who controls
what for the next two years. One such race is the
Georgia Senate race, where incumbent Democratic
Senator Raphael Warnock is trying to beat off
an attack from former football player Herschel
Walker. As you know, Herschel Walker can barely
speak. He certainly seems unable to think. He's
not able to explain his position coherently on any
issue. He appeared over the weekend with Fox News.
Trump Brown Noser Maria BARTIROMO. And it is truly
frightening that this could be one of 100 members
of the U.S. Senate being a completely incoherent.
Individual, which we have become accustomed to.
But picking up on words he's hearing elsewhere.
Without any idea how to use them here, claiming
that they are bringing pronouns to the military.
Speaker 3: Right now he's called our men and
women in blue. Thugs and bullies. They
bring in pronouns at our military. But
they're saying it's the Republicans fault.
Speaker 1: Yeah. They're bringing pronouns to the
military. I hate to break it to you, Herschel.
They're using verbs, they're using nouns,
they're using adverbs. It's. They're even using
prepositional phrases in the military. He hears
something that sounds like what he's supposed to
be saying, and he repeats it and he has no clue
what he is talking about. In another moment during
this interview. Of all the different threats to
the United States that we're dealing with right
now, he says the real threat is that Raphael
Warnock will vote against the Keystone pipeline.
Speaker 4: Failing now 48 hours away.
Speaker 3: Well, I feel pretty good. You know,
when you have a president talking about the
biggest threat to democracy, you seem to be
elected in a Republican. But I want everyone
to listen to me. The biggest threat to democracy
is to have him in the White House. And the biggest
threat to democracy is to have some guys.
Speaker 1: I mean, listen, I it is it nit
picky that he can't say democracy, that he called
it demographically three times during this leg is
that, you know, you point these things out and
these right wingers go, David, that's racist. I,
I thought you were the ones who said we were
racist when we see race. I'm not mentioning the
guy's race. I'm telling you, he can't speak or
think. And now Repub. Oh, yuk. David What? Huh?
The guy is completely incoherent.
Speaker 3: Right, Senator? Why not
to vote against our Keystone Pipeline? Oh,
God. Put us in an international threat.
I think right now that's a that's a threat.
Speaker 1: And it puts us in a threat when war
knock votes against Keystone. Explain that to me.
Speaker 3: As a security threat going to our
enemies. As for energy, that's a threat. That's a
bigger threat to democracy there. And all got men
and women sports which he voted for that right.
Speaker 1: That's another big threat to
the country. Men in women's
sports. An issue affecting.
Zero point what? 0.05. I mean, come on, guys,
there. And Maria BARTIROMO enables it. They
all enabled it by pretending this is normal.
Speaker 3: Biggest threat to democracy is how
do people, the Democrats right now lead in
this country because they seem to be taking
this country in the wrong direction. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Give me the indicators, Hershel.
Give me the specific indicators by which you can
make that case. So here's the good news and the
bad news, and they're both the same. Anybody could
win this race. I know that many of you were very
worried because of this gap that was closed by
Herschel Walker, which now has Herschel Walker
ahead by half a point on average. I'm going
to be very direct and frank with all of you.
Who the hell cares what the polls say right
now? Many people writing to me saying, David,
a lot of these polls are right wing biased.
Remington is a right wing poll. As an example,
Remington has Walker plus four. Here's the way
to think about it. This thing is tied. Okay.
Some of the specific polls are literally a tie.
Like the recent Marist poll. Even if you average
all the polls, including the supposed right wing
polls, it's half a point that separates these two.
Anybody can win if you believe that the polls
are biased towards Walker, but that early voter
turnout favors Warnock. But just go and vote
if you vote in Georgia. If you believe Walker's
really winning, then go and vote and make it
so that his margin shrinks by one vote. All we
have to do is go and vote. And we will very soon
know whether one of the most humiliating realities
about the Senate will become a reality or whether
we can avoid a complete and total disaster.